cet homme vit seule avec son frère et
pour quelle raison parce qu'il faut être
deux
dire qu'il n'y avait pas trouvé de
femmes
bien sûr
il n'y a pas de femmes dans la région
mais c'est qu'elles veulent pas faire
râler
mais là c'est à dire les femmes vont se
marier à lille c'est la vie est plus
agréable si chez nous une femme et que
vous voulez une femme et elle travaille
comme un homme il faut qu'elle est
d'aller table il faut qu'elle s'assoit
en plus de ces lessives quelle façon
ménages wissam temps passé
et alors vous avez vécu toute vie sans
femme ça vous a pas posé de problème et
il se pose bien des problèmes le bio est
obligé de se débrouiller comme on peut
tous ceux qui ont leurs parents
célibataires qui ont encore leurs
parents ils restent ici d'autre part les
parents font partie aussi on sait pas on
entame d'art ils sont là peut être qu'on
est intéressé par une certaine vie et
qu'on se plaît dans cette vie et donc on
reste célibataire